right we have the opportunity and indeed
the responsibility whoa to swing for the
fences so that we can ensure Florida
remains number one don't worry about the
chattering class ignore all the
backgrounds now remember Florida is I I
love Florida parts of it
but it's not number one in anything it's
not number one in business
infrastructure health education crime I
mean it's just it's a very it's a it's a
fine State it's a mediocre State ranked
between 20 and 30 in just about every
category
keep the compass set to True North right
we will stand strong we will hold the
line we won't back down and I can
promise you this
you ain't seen nothing yet thank you all
beautifully delivered bless you God
bless you yeah
um just so this is a preview of what a
DeSantis presidential campaign would be
like